Dominic Robb is returning his Justice
secretary and has that role of Deputy pm
and we were talking about that role Beth
just remind us
the depth CPM role yeah well I mean
isn't it incredible I mean he was Deputy
PM under uh Boris Johnson
and he's also been Justice secretary
before and in fact what he was trying to
do was be quite tough on some of the
legislation around the Human Rights Act
you know there's been all these issues
about this Rwanda policy to send
migrants to Rwanda there's been lots of
legal
hurdles to that policy I should say
Rishi sunak has committed uh to that
policy and so he's brought Robin he
knows that brief well bringing him to
execute that thing but also if you if
you are the deputy uh prime minister you
also stand in uh you'll stand in for the
prime minister at pmqs you know when
Boris Johnson was in hospital it was
Dominic Robb do you remember that when
he was in hospital in intensive care
with covid standing up there giving the
evening press conference yeah
absolutely delighted with that so
Dominic Raab is the Justice secretary
Jeremy Hunt is the chancellor I think
that Oliver Dowden will be the
chancellor of the Dutch of Lancaster but
we don't know that speculation